the incredibly rich fantasy world of on
wood is positively bursting with Easter
eggs and amazing hidden details from
deep cut Toy Story and Pixar references
to secret marvel infinity gauntlets
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers I'm John and
in this video I'll be revealing 50 of
the very best Easter eggs and hidden
details to look out for in onward
there'll be a few mild spoilers ahead
but I'll avoid any major plot reveals
pixels dedication to recurring Easter
eggs has fueled the idea that their
movies exist in a single shared universe
and there's a fascinating connection
between onward and brave that fans of
the Pixar theory will likely love when
barley and ian are looking at the map
for how to get to Ravens point there's
an area called the brave wilderness
which is also next to Locke Lake brave
is set in the Scottish Highlands and
during the brothers trip they pass by
some ruins stone buildings that fit the
scenery of parts of rural Scotland
there's even some tall stones which have
fallen over and could possibly have been
part of an old ring of stones similar to
where Merida sees the wisps for the
first time another Pixar universe
connection and on wood is the appearance
of triple dense gum you can spot the
pixie dust as grabbing it at the gas
station and Ian also has a packet
underneath his old tape player at home
triple dent gum is of course the chewing
gum brand from inside out with that very
memorable jingle that Reilly couldn't
get out of her head also in the gas
station is a very sneaky Toy Story
reference via a tiny little cup with
pens on the cashiers counter the chicken
logo is from poultry palace the
fast-food restaurant that Bonnie and her
family visited on their road trip in Toy
Story for poultry palace first appeared
in the Toy Story short film small fry
and there was also a vintage ye olde
poultry palace sign in the antique store
in two story four by the way if he
missed it at the time Toy Story 4 had an
Easter Egg for Tom wood in one of its
mid-credits scenes the winged Pegasus
design on a bouncy castle at the
carnival is the same one as on the side
of Bali's Van Guinevere the Pizza Planet
truck from Pixar's first Toy Story movie
which has appeared in almost every Pixar
film so far he's referenced several ways
in onward liking koko where the truck
was rebranded as Pete
Planeta in onward the name has been
changed to pizza realm fitting better
with the film's old-world sensibilities
the pits around design still has the
iconic planet however a mast and banner
have also been added and the font has
been given a vintage look
you can also spot a Pete's around truck
queuing in the traffic at the toll booth
as barley and ian's begin their quest
also watch out for the cooler in the
back of Bali's fan as it has a pizza
realm sticker on it though it's hard to
spot as the box moves around a lot as
they drive in keeping with its themes of
wizardry and spell casting onward pays
homage to a number of other magical
fantasy Disney movies some of the staff
at the manticores tavern were hats that
are very similar to the Sorcerer's hat
which Mickey Mouse first wore in
Disney's Fantasia the Sorcerer's hat is
iconic in Disney history it has appeared
in many other Disney productions from
wreck-it Ralph to to Once Upon a Time
the store calls sword in the scone in
onward which is a nod to Disney's
animated fantasy movie the sword in the
stone and that Pern is a double Easter
egg because sword in the scone is also
the name of the breakfast sandwich on
the menu at poultry palace in Toy Story
4 and small fry look carefully when Ian
walks into the gas station because there
are magic beans on sale a reference to
the fairy tale of Jack and the Beanstalk
and anon wood as Ian and barley go on
their quest they drive right through
fields filled with giant bean stalks
that stretch all the way into the clouds
visually these are some very striking
scenes but they might have originally
been planned as an easter egg too
Disney's animated movie gigantic an
adaptation of Jack and the Beanstalk
which was few to release the same year
as onward until it was cancelled Tom
Holland and Chris Pratt are the voices
of Ian and barley in onward but as
actors they're both particularly well
known for their portrayals of spider-man
and star-lord in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and so it's inevitable that
Pixar has squeezed numerous Marvel
references and easter eggs into the
movie first of all on Barley's jacket
there's an Infinity Gauntlet
much like the one famously wielded by
Thanos in Marvel's infinity saga there's
also a sticker with the same design plus
the word gauntlet underneath it on the
back of the passenger seat inside
Barney's van the tiny red skull pin on
Bally's jacket could be a nod to the
Marvel villain
skull who becomes the guardian of the
soul stone in the Marvel verse before
this red skull was the head of Hydra in
the MCU and there's a potential nod to
that organization by the Hydra badge on
Barney's jacket right trap though of
course Hydra is also a deadly multi
headed serpent from Greek and Roman
mythology as well as a Dungeons &
Dragons monster more on D&D Easter eggs
later and the Phoenix gem which brings
the brothers father back to life is
orange colored just like the MCU soul
stone in onward the gem gives in and
barley our data interact with their dead
father and an Avengers infinity war the
soul stone temporarily allowed Thanos to
communicate with his dead daughter
Gamora when he was in the soul world and
Varley who's voiced by Chris Pratt
shares a similar characteristic with
Pratt's MCU character star-lord aka
Peter quill both characters have a love
of mixtapes and both of them had a
traumatic experience as a child when one
of their parents died in onward barly
regrets that he didn't go in to say
goodbye to his father when he was ill
because he was scared of all the tubes
and how unwell he was and when his
mother was about to die in guardians of
the galaxy as a child Peter quill
couldn't bear to hold her hand or look
at her something he would also later
regret Ian who's voiced by Tom Holland
was red and blue colors just like
spider-man who he plays in the MCU and
when Ian says he'll do whatever it takes
to meet his dad it echoes a famous line
for avengers endgame this is the fight
of our lives whatever it takes
onward also includes many hats hips to
other fantasy pop culture and movies
when Ian visits a fast-food restaurant
there's a sign for second breakfast a
nod to JRR Tolkien's The Hobbit in which
Bilbo Baggins likes to eat a second
breakfast something also true the
hobbits and Peter Jackson's Lord of the
Rings trilogy what about breakfast
you've already had it we've had one yes
what about second breakfast and the lor
on varley's quest mixtape is possibly
another nod to Lord of the Rings Farley
later plays a special mixtape titled
rise to Valhalla when he sends his
beloved Van Guinevere off on her final
mission Valhalla is a sacred place in
Norse mythology where many fallen
warriors go to after death the details
in this scene are perfect with Barley's
parking tickets fluttering
the windows giving the sense that
Guinevere has wings and the sound of the
Vans tires on the stones creates a
galloping sound as if she is riding into
battle Dungeons and Dragons is also a
huge inspiration for onward there's
Barley's quest of your role-playing game
complete with a guide that resembles a
D&D manual with spell casting
instructions and the cover of the book
cleverly foreshadows an important moment
later in the movie on Barley's jacket
there's a d20 dice which for anyone
unfamiliar is a 20-sided dice used in
Dungeons and Dragons Bolly also has a
d20 die stitching with lightning bolts
on his jacket sleeve the gelatinous cube
which Ian and barley encounter after
they venture into some caves is a
classic D&D monster taken directly from
the game the oozing cube is an
antagonist that can absorb and digest
the victims it traps and the many other
murderous traps in the caves corridors
give this scene an Indiana Jones vibe
together with the way that Inn and
barley pulled their fathers legs through
the closing stone door just in the nick
of time
much like Indies famous hat grab in the
Temple of Doom another eighties
reference comes at the end of onward
when instead of driving off in volleys
van along the road the van flies away
with the power of magic mimicking the
end of Back to the Future when Doc
returns with his time machine car from
the future and then he Marty and
Jennifer fly away instead of driving
down the road and that back to the
future reference seems especially
fitting given the recent deep fake of
Tom Holland as Marty McFly as always in
every Pixar film there's a cameo from
John Ratzenberger who's one of the
construction workers that yells at
barley when he's getting in the way of
the demolition of the stone fountain
towards the end of the movie office of
Broncos called him for duty with the
police reporting that there's an a.1 1/3
in progress a 1 1 3 is a regular Pixar
Easter Egg that's a tribute to the
California Institute of the Arts
classroom where many of Pixar's animator
studied in Ian and Bali's kitchen
there's a nod to Disney's Sleeping
Beauty and Maleficent with an Aurora
branded washing up liquid and on one of
the shelves in Ian's room there's a
wooden dinosaur figure that resembles
the mysterious Pecola
different Pixar's the good dinosaur
onward is also chock-full of sign and
brand gags great pans and other
pop-culture references in the opening
sequence as a scene in an arcade where a
Center is playing a game called prance
prance revolution a play on the music
video game dance dance revelution at
home the boy's mother Laura uses way
strong chocolate flavor protein powder
for our smoothies and Ian eats trolley
Oh cereal are likely pan on Cheerios
other brand-name gags include cloak and
cola clearly coca-cola mountain doom
onwards version of Mountain Dew which is
also a nod to Lord of the Rings Mount
Doom and saturated a pan on Gatorade
it's also funny that the troll at a toll
booth works for the under bridge
transportation authority a joke about
how trolls in some fairy tales like
three Billy Goats Gruff wait underneath
bridges to prey on those who try to
cross and it also made me chuckle when I
noticed you can either pay the troll
with cash or a riddle now what other
Easter eggs or cool details do you spot
in onward and do you have any theories
on where the movie fits into the Pixar
universe leave your thoughts in the
comments below
if you enjoyed this don't forget to
leave a like and subscribe for all my
new videos tap left for another Pixar
video or tap write for something you're
sure to like thanks for watching and see
you next time you PK movie lovers